المعلومات التي تحدث عن دور معاويه في
تاسيس هذه النظم والدواوين هي ما توافر
عليه كثير من المؤرخين في المصادر الاصيله
والمصادر الكلاسيكيه في التاريخ الاسلامي
نتحدث عن الطبري ابن كثير وابن كثير
والبلاذري والمسعودي وكثير ممن كتبوا عن
سيره وتاريخ الدوله الامويه حتى من مناويي
الدوله الامويه هم يؤكدون على دور معاويه
بن سفيان في تاسيس مثل هذه الامور ومن
اشهر هذه المؤلفات هناك نمط في التاليف
كتب الاوائل والتي تحدث عن اول من فعل كذا
اول من فعل كذا من ابرزها مثلا كتاب
الاوائل لا بهلال العسكري وفيه فصل
الاوائل في الملك وفي هذا الفصل ياتي
معاويه بن ابي سفيان رضي الله عنه اول ملك
في الاسلام اول من وضع نظام ديوان البريد
اول من وضع ديوان الختم وهكذا هذه كلها
معلومات
متوافره وتوافر واكدها كثير من المؤرخين
والباحثين في مصادر التاريخ الاسلامي
الاصيله اعظم ملوك العرب مايو سفيان
هذا الامر او هذا اللقب هذا الامر او هذا
اللقب انه اعظم ملوك العرب يعني اشار اليه
وذكره عدد من المحققين والعلماء السابقين
ذكروا بهذا اللفظ ونصه على ان معابر هو
اعظم ملوك العرب ونحن ممكن نقول انه فعلا
هو واحد من اعظم
من اعظم ملوك العرب التي اثروا الدكتور
جورج صليبه ويمكن هو كذلك
واهم خليفه اموي لا اعلم اذا كان هو له
راي مخالف في هذا الشان او شيء لكنه هو
ايضا عبد الملك بن مروان شخصيه عظيمه جدا
ومؤثره في التاريخ الاسلامي واثر عظيم
وائل وهو المؤسس الثاني للدوله الامويه
واثاره هائله في بناء ايضا الحضاره
العربيه والاسلاميه اللي يسمعك بهذه
الطريقه تصف معاويه يعني انت تشوف وتسمع
انه انت بالغت كثيرا وربما انه انت تشترك
مع الناس هذول في في بهذا الطرح الكبير
بهذا التعصب وتاخذها من منطلق كذلك
كل ما تحدثت معه اشعر بانني لم انطلق من
منطلقات دينيه وانما حاولت ان اقدم شواهد
بمصادر مثل ايش المصادر
التاريخيه
تاريخ الطبري تاريخ ابن الاثير تاريخ ابن
كثير
كما يقال لها اتفق عليها العلماء
والمؤرخون انا كل ما ذكرت لك ربما لا ترى
في اي جانب ديني هو مجرد احداث دنيويه
احداث دنيويه وشواهد تؤكد حول الاثر
الحضاري التي صنعته هذا الشخصيه